[Music]
us humans are like ships lost in the
ocean of life we seek stable land and
hope for guidance from the ocean's
current only to have it carry us on its
own uncertain course this often brings
us towards feelings of helplessness and
confusion and causes us to desire to
give up control as the captain of our
ship we look for someone or something to
give us a break from the difficulty of
navigating this relief often comes in
the form of intoxicating substances
intoxicating substances allude to being
worthy captains of our ship but their
destination is often limited to the
shores of their own abuse the greatest
hardship of life is life itself we are
in constant battle against its
complexities and illusions when we don't
take the necessary steps to deal with
such complexities and illusions we are
forced to dwell on them dwelling on the
difficulties of life forms knots in the
wiring of our brain just like a knot in
a muscle these knots restrict our range
of mental motion and inhibit a healthy
operation of life in our efforts to
loosen and alleviate these knots we
often find ourself at the foot of
intoxicating substances but the end of
the rope that they pull usually only
further tightens them humans are one of
the only creatures on planet Earth to
purposely form habit out of altering
their own brain this is likely a product
of the complex maze that exists between
ourselves and the world and drugs create
an illusion of smoothness
using pleasure stimulating and
mind-altering substances is not always
harmful but the problem is our inability
to understand how to sometimes create
this same smoothness upon our own it is
this that causes the misuse and overuse
of intoxicating substances and it is
this that we must be concerned about
people are not accomplices to the crime
of drug abuse people are victims of
life's complexity and mortality and
drugs are merely a byproduct and as a
culture we must understand and be
compassionate towards this in order to
understand how to appropriately handle
substance abuse problems we must first
make sure we are appropriately handling
human ones